we are told it is so horrific it is so
awful but Joe Biden managed to show up
yesterday and wander around Ukraine here
you go significant Moment On The World
stage President Biden met with Ukrainian
president of the Vladimir zielinski
during this unannounced trip it comes
just days before the one-year Mark of
Russia's brutal invasion of Ukraine all
right Biden's there I would imagine then
that Biden might be saying hey we got to
wrap this thing up let's look for a way
out right because that would be the same
thing to do I mean we got our own
problems in the U.S so hey zielinski can
we tie this thing together or
remind us that freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for
as long as it takes
and that's how long we're going to be
with you Mr President for as long as it
takes
we'll do it
oh we're going to be there for as long
as it takes I don't know maybe 20 years
you know we just got out of this
freaking Afghanistan thing we were there
for 20 years nobody knows why
billions and trillions of dollars all
the millions of deaths Iraq war a lot of
dead people Carnage you know collapsing
infrastructure everywhere none of it
really working let's just get in it
let's just get in we'll just hang out
for a couple years I don't know a couple
decades just keep funding the thing you
know come on we're Americans
[Music]
foreign